The first thing I'll do is I'll ask the user for a value. Could be a floating
point value because the water could have gone down by a fractional amount. I'll
read the next double and if the value is negative, I'll increment the counter.
Now, if I want the user to keep on entering more values, I'll need to tell them
that. And it looks like I forgot colon space on the first one. That wouldn't
have looked very pretty. Fix that in my compile errors, and it looks like I'm
ready to go. If I run the program, I can enter values, and I've entered two
negative values now, so if I finish, I expect to see the count as two. And if
looks like the water line fell on two years. I'd probably want to fix out the
spacing before I shared this. But right now I'm counting all of the negative
numbers just the way I wanted to.